مشاهدينا هذه التطورات تتزامن مع تصاعد
الخلافات في الداخل الاسرائيلي فقد قال بن
جانس الوزير في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي ان
مشاركه وزراء واعضاء من الائتلاف الحاكم
في مؤتمر دع الى اعاده الاستيطان في غزه
اضرت بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي وشرعيه اسرائيل
امام المجتمع الدولي وبالجهود المبذوله من
اجل اعاده الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه
من المهم ان ندرك ويدرك العالم ان من يتخذ
القرارات في نهايه الامر هو مجلس الحرب
والمجلس الوزاري المصغر من رقص وقسم الشعب
في المؤتمر يوم امس لا يقرر ومن يصمت
وينجر خلفهم ليس قائدا المسؤوليه تحتم علي
وعلى اصدقائ البقاء في الكابينت والحكومه
كي نتخذ القرارات الصعبه صائبه التي
تنتظرنا وكي نحافظ على دولتنا قويه وموحده
في وقت الضيق لذا نحن في الحكومه وحين
استقرار الوضع سنعود للشعب وعندها تقول
الجماهير
كلمتها